- [Instructor] As we get
into the late Heian period,
you start to have the emergence of a
increasingly powerful warrior class.
And all of that comes to
a head in the year 1185,
when the Heian period ends and a general
by the name of Minamoto
Yoritomo comes to power.
And what's significant here
is the notion of an emperor
continues to exist, but
all of the power resides
in what you can essentially
consider a military dictator,
or a shogun.
And the system that emerges
is known as the bakufu system
or the shogunate.
And Minamoto Yuritomo
was the first shogun.
So you can see here, the
emperor still was there,
but the shogun was where
all of the power was.
And this is really the beginning
of medieval Japan.
It's the beginning of the Kamakura period,
named for where the capital
of the Kamakura period was.
Now what's distinctive
about medieval Japan
and the bakufu system,
is that it becomes much more decentralized
than what we had under the Heian period.
It's often called a feudal system,
because it has parallels
to what was going on
in Europe at around the same time.
Where at the top you had this
military ruler, the shogun,
and then beneath the shogun
you had this decentralized structure
of these lords, essentially,
that controlled significant
regions of Japan.
They were called the daimyo.
And there were roughly
300 daimyo in Japan,
roughly county sized districts.
And the daimyo, in order conquer land,
or to protect their own land,
they would support a warrior
class known as the samurai.
And so they would take their agricultural
surplus from their lands,
and use that to support
this warrior class.
And this warrior class, the samurai,
they were analogous to
knights in medieval Europe
and just as the knights
had chivalry in Europe,
the samurai in Japan had bushido
which eventually emerges
as their code of conduct.
Despite that decentralized nature,
they were able to fend off
invasions from Kublai Khan.
So as we've mentioned in other videos
in the 1270s, Kublai Khan
is conquering much of China
and he also attempts to conquer Japan.
This right over here is
a picture of the Mongols
shooting arrows at a samurai warrior.
Now one of the key factors that keeps
Kublai Khan from taking over Japan
is on two different occasions
as they send their boats
from what we now consider
to be Korea to Japan
they encounter significant
storms that destroy
most of the boats, and so the Mongols
who are able to get to land
are significantly depleted
and they're pushed back
by the samurai warriors.
Now the Kamakura period
continues on until 1333
when there is a brief, only
a few years restoration
of the power of the emperor,
but a few years after that
another shogun comes to power
and that is Ashikaga Takauji.
And this is the beginning
now of the Muromachi period.
The Muromachi period is often
known as the Ashikaga period
or the Ashikaga shogunate,
but it's named Muromachi
for the district of Kyoto
at which it had its capital.
And even though over the
course of the Muromachi period
the emperor at different points
was subsumed into the power of the shogun,
this is considered especially
the later Muromachi period
as one of the more fragmented
times of Japanese history.
You had many civil wars.
You had a lot of internal conflict,
and it was only at the end as we get
to the end of the 16th Century
that Japan gets reunified.
And one of the key factors that allows it
to get reunified is that in
the middle of the 16th Century
Portuguese traders show up and
they introduce guns to Japan.
And one daimyo in
particular is able to take
significant advantage of those guns,
and that is Oda Nobunaga.
Oda Nobunaga as I mentioned
was a powerful daimyo,
one of these lords who controlled
what you could kind of consider
to be a county of Japan
and using these guns, he's able to put
most of the other daimyos,
most of the other lords
into submission, and he begins
to significantly unify Japan.
Now he is eventually
assassinated and his successor
Toyotomi Hideyoshi continues
to unify Japan even further.
When he dies, Tokugawa Ieyasu takes power
and he's able to consolidate even further
and definitively becomes
the ruling shogun of Japan.
Now even though this
period that we're entering,
the Edo period and it's
named for the castle Edo
from which the Tokugawa shogunate ruled,
even though this continues
to be a shogunate
with a shogun in power at
the top, the bakufu system,
the reason why this is
considered the beginning
of the modern period or
the early modern period
is that Japan was finally unified again.
Now one thing that we will see
as we get into the 19th Century,
as we get into the end of the Edo period
and then you have the Meiji restoration
where you have imperial rule again
is that Japan is very good
at borrowing technology
and ideas from other cultures
and then making it their own.
We saw that in the classical period
where they imported ideas
of Confucianism, Buddhism,
imperial government from the Chinese,
but adding their own flavor to it
and we will see it again as
we get into the 19th Century
when Japan is one of the first
countries not just in Asia,
but in the world to truly industrialize
by learning many of the technologies
that get pioneered in the west.